okay this video is on the
interpretations of quantum physics
which i've been down a little bit of a
rabbit hole over the last
couple of months if i'm honest because
the interpretations of quantum physics
aren't easy to understand
and i thought hey i'll do a video on
those that'll be fun
and then i did my research and looked
into it and then
kind of my brain melted so anyway this
is my best
effort at the interpretations of quantum
physics i hope you enjoy
so what are they well first of all
there's a hole in the bottom of physics
when you're down at the level of atoms
and subatomic particles
you're in the realm of quantum physics
and there's some things in quantum
physics that
simply just don't make sense physicists
don't like things not making sense and
so
the interpretations of quantum physics
an an attempt by many different
physicists to come up with ways of
making quantum physics make sense
now if you're not familiar with the
terminology of quantum physics i
recommend you watch my last video
because it's kind of an introduction to
quantum physics and this video
is a sort of part two to that
so interpretation number one is the
copenhagen interpretation
and that's kind of the standard way
we're talk quantum physics
when we learn it in university and it's
also kind of the place where i can
illustrate where some of the problems
start happening so
in the copenhagen interpretation the
standard description is
is that subatomic particles like an
electron is described by a wave function
and this wave function obeys the
schrodinger equation
which tells us how that wave sort of
smoothly evolves
over time and features of this wave
gives us all the properties of quantum
physics that people talk about like
superposition entanglement
energy quantization decoherence quantum
tunneling
all of those things are phenomena that
appear because of
the wave-like nature of sub-atomic
particles
so the conceptual problems begin when we
do a measurement on these waves
so the copenhagen picture of quantum
physics is you have
a wave function moving along smoothly
according to the schrodinger equation
until it hits an object like a detector
and then what we see what we measure as
a human
is a single particle in a specific
position
which means that the wave function which
is like
spread out over space when it hits the
detector it suddenly collapses
it's called localization so the wave
localizes from a spread out wave to a
very
sharply defined wave where we see the
particle
the trouble is there's no actual
physics in quantum mechanics that
describes how that collapse
happens and this is known as the
measurement problem
so this measurement is sort of a
barrier which shields the quantum realm
we can never see those
wave functions or we can ever see a
particles
and in the copenhagen interpretation of
quantum physics what they say
is like we're us humans we'll never see
those waves there's nothing we can do to
access that realm
so don't worry wondering whether they're
real or not real
the important thing are the measurements
reality is in the observations
which is why it's been termed the shut
up and calculate interpretation of
quantum physics
but people have not stopped there they
don't like this discontinuous collapse
of the wave functions they've come up
with other
ways of trying to interpret what's going
on and this brings us to the second
interpretation i'm going to cover the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
physics
so the many worlds interpretation
quantum physics takes
the wave function to be physically real
and says if the schrodinger equation is
just a description of reality what does
reality look like
so what it says is that when you do a
measurement on a particle that's in a
superposition of many different places
at once
actually that particle turns up at all
of those different places
just in different versions of reality
another way to think of it is if a
particle is in a superposition of two
places at once
and it hits a detector it now puts that
detector in a superposition of measuring
the particle in one place or another
and if you look at the results from that
detector then it puts you in a
superposition
of seeing the particle in one place or
seeing a particle in
another place but because the results of
one place or another are mutually
exclusive it means that
now your universe between the two u's
have
decohered from each other are now split
into separate branches
so a superposition is described by a
wave function so really there's just
one giant mega wave function that
describes
all of the possibilities that could ever
have happened in the entire history of
the universe
so if there's an interpretation quantum
physics that you've heard about it'll be
this one the many worlds interpretation
because it seems to capture public
consciousness and i think it's because
people like the idea that if you've made
like a really bad decision that you
regret in the past
you can kind of take comfort in the
belief that there's another universe out
there
where you made a better decision and so
there's a version of you who's happy
right now
it also seems to be a very useful
storytelling technique in
films that want to have different sort
of realities
like it was just in the into the
spider-man into the spider-verse for the
different kinds of
well i shouldn't ruin the plot anyway
it's a good film it also seems to be
pretty popular amongst physicists
although i'm not such a huge fan of it
because one of the problems is it breaks
probability
so imagine if you've got a particle
that's in a 30
probability of being here and a 70
probability of being here when it hits
the detector
it splits into two universes where it
definitely is with a hundred percent
probability it's in one place and a
hundred
percent probability it's in the other
place so if
everything all happens what do those
original probabilities actually mean
this problem is addressed in a
interpretation
called the cosmological interpretation
which says that many worlds theory is
trivially true if the universe is
infinitely
big because there's an infinite number
of views
doing that experiment and those that
infinite number just splits in
proportion
so thirty percent of those infinite u's
will see one thing and seventy percent
of those infinite u's will see the other
thing
unfortunately there's no experiments
that we can actually run to see if this
interpretation is more valid than the
copenhagen interpretation
and that's actually a general feature of
all of these interpretations is that we
can't
pick them apart with any experiments and
so until we have experiments
it's all kind of like physics-y
storytelling
let's now look at another aspect of
quantum physics that doesn't quite make
sense to us
which is called non-locality otherwise
known as spooky action at a distance
and this can be summarized by the epr
experiment which is where you take
two particles say electrons and you
entangle them together to have equal
and opposite spins say and then you
separate them by a very very large
distance because they are now
inextricably linked the wave function
that describes them has to describe
both particles and what this means
in reality is when you do a measurement
on one of these particles it
instantaneously influences the other one
which can be you know billions of miles
away and it does that
instantaneously so it sort of feels like
faster than light action that's the
action at a distance
which einstein was really creeped out by
so non-locality means that
one electron its properties
are not local to its physical place its
properties
are dependent on something very very far
away and this is an alien concept in
physics because
if i throw a ball the ball's position or
velocity
or color or anything physical to do with
that ball they're all localized to where
that ball
physically is whereas in quantum physics
you can have things that are non-local
and that seems weird to a physicist
because you're like
all physics is like this except for this
one bit here
in quantum physics so this has
spawned other interpretations of quantum
physics like trying to explain away this
one
and one of these is called hidden
variable theories
so the idea in a hidden variable theory
is that when you do this entanglement
there's some secret label which captures
the actual state of these two particles
so it's like if i flip a coin and i hold
it in my hands even though i don't know
whether it's heads or tails
the coin actually is heads or tails when
it's in my hand and i just reveal it
when i open up my hands
so that's kind of what these hidden
variable theories are
the particles are in a definite position
we just don't know what it is until we
measure it
now this interpretation was actually
killed by an experiment called
bell's theorem i'm not going to go into
the details of this because i don't have
time
but basically the hidden variable theory
and quantum physics
predict different probabilities of you
observing certain things
under bell's experiment and when they
did the experiment they actually found
the results
match quantum physics and not hidden
variable theories
so hidden variables are out now it's not
completely game over for the hidden
variable theories because
bell's theorem is built on some
axioms some things that you assume to be
true and one of these
is locality and so you
can have a successful non-local
hidden variable theory also known as
bohmian mechanics also
known as pilot wave theory now the idea
in this
interpretation is that the particles are
always real but they're kind of surfing
about
on an underlying wave and so
when you see the probability of
particles appearing in different places
it's because they've been nudged in
different directions by this underlying
wave
but still we can't see those waves and
the advantage of this
is that it kind of returns quantum
physics to a sort of determinism
which none of the other interpretations
of quantum physics do
but the trouble again is there's no
testable hypothesis so there's no way of
us doing an
experiment to see if it's true so
another thread
in the interpretations of quantum
physics is
to instead focus on the collapse of the
wave function
and try and make that bit make sense so
there are interpretations called
alternative collapse theories that try
and add some extra
physics into that collapse either
explain why it happens or
adds like describe the dynamics of
exactly how the wave function
localizes one idea called spontaneous
collapse
theory is that the wave function has got
a probability of
collapsing at any time a bit like sort
of radioactive decay
so for a small particle there's a very
low probability that its wave function
collapses maybe like once in a hundred
million years
whereas for big groups of particles
together in like a football
there would be way more collapses
because if any one of those collapses
it has a knock-on effect to collapse the
wave functions of
all the others and so there'd be maybe
100 million collapses per second
which kind of goes some way to describe
why the world we experience
is all kind of solid and deterministic
and the quantum realm isn't so it
describes kind of the boundary
between those things and the advantage
of this interpretation
is it's actually making a testable
prediction
and so at some stage in the future we
could design an experiment that could
maybe see if it's true or not
so you know it doesn't say that it's any
more likely to be true than
any of the others but at least it's got
a testable prediction which is an
experimental physicist
i like so those are the main
interpretations of quantum physics but
there's many many more i'm just going to
cover a few more here
but this isn't an exhaustive list
also word of warning this is where i
started to get really rather confused
so let's proceed with some amount of
caution
first up is quantum bayesianism also
known as
cubism which takes the ideas of
bayesian probability and applies it to
quantum physics
so sort of like a informational theory
of quantum physics and the idea as i
understand it is that
when you get new information about a
state it updates the probabilities of
the things that you will measure
the consistent history is interpretation
quantum physics apparently the
mathematics is somewhat of a hybrid
between
hidden variable theories and spontaneous
collapse theories
it includes spontaneous collapses of the
wave function
but different aspects not just position
can collapse
it also says that those collapses aren't
physical events
but just a way of you picking through a
history
of that quantum object that makes sense
that's consistent
the next one's quantum darwinism which
is where
when the quantum system interacts with
the environment
certain things are killed off so
interactions between particles in the
environment are kind of like natural
selection for the properties of that
quantum object
another interpretation is called the
transactional interpretation
which in the actual mathematics of
quantum physics it allows solutions that
travel
backwards in time as well as forwards in
time but we normally just throw away the
backwards in time ones because you know
you're gonna travel backwards in time
but like i don't know maybe you can so
that's what the transactional
interpretation it keeps those
and says that the properties that you
have
may be dependent on things that happen
to you in the future
and this is attractive because it can
actually get around bell's theorem
another one is called the relational
interpretation which doesn't focus
on the properties of quantum objects but
everything's defined by the relations
between
them so those are the main
interpretations of quantum physics
there's a few others but those are the
main ones i sometimes get asked what is
my favorite interpretation
and i don't really have one my
thoughts about this uh because there's
so many different interpretations of
quantum physics it's kind of a sign that
we might be
missing something kind of fundamental
so maybe one way to attack this problem
is to really go
back to first principles and back to the
fundamental assumptions of quantum
physics because there's some interesting
assumptions that were made
like when you have a wave function which
predicts probabilities of things happen
that was just a guess and it works
really really well but there was no
real reason for that other than nice
guesswork
so yeah quantum
physics is going to
[Music]
well that's the end thanks for sticking
through all of that i hope it was of
interest
i think you've earned yourself a nice
sit down and maybe even a biscuit
so thanks for watching and thanks also
to the sponsor of this video
skillshare i always get loads of
comments asking me how
i produce my videos and what software i
use and the truth is it's a combination
of all the adobe software illustrator
photoshop after effects and premiere and
skillshare is a fantastic website if you
want to learn any of these programs for
your own creative projects
as well as covering the adobe software
they've got more than 18 000
classes covering everything from drawing
writing through to film production
their premium subscription service
unlocks all of these lessons which are
delivered by trained professionals in
their fields
but if you want to get a head start you
can get a two month free trial for the
first 500 people to click on this link
the link is also in the description
below
well that's it from me thanks for
watching and i'll see you next time
you